turning now to our new series on the
growing problems with child care
nationwide and some potential solutions
we think in our look at america's child
care crisis we found the pandemic and
low wages have made things worse for
families and providers too you know
parents are struggling to get help
especially care they can afford
care they can afford that's the question
at the same time daycare say it's just
hard to find and keep good staff so we
begin our series today with meg oliver
reporting from montana
it's the most devastating decision i've
ever had to make
in my life cindy moats never imagined
that after more than 35 years in
business she would be forced to close
her daycare her facility serves around
100 kids in billings montana
moats cannot find and keep staff before
the pandemic she had around 35 to 40
employees now she says she's down to
about 15 not enough to stay open i can
only do so much when i can't get a
workforce i can't do this job to my
expectation or anybody's expectation
without a workforce
a survey from the national association
for the education of young children
found that four in five day cares
nationwide are understaffed 78 percent
of those surveyed said low wages are the
main reason it's hard to recruit new
employees how hard is it to find
affordable child care it is
extremely hard
if you don't have a job then you can't
afford to have child care while you're
looking for one if you get a job you
have to have child care almost
immediately so that you can start
but there aren't any spaces available
sarah smith works at explore montessori
academy in bozeman montana one two three
go her three-year-old daughter attends
daycare here in return smith gets an
almost 30 percent discount for her child
care if you're paying for child care you
can't stay for college for your child
there's things that you can get that
your kids might need trips and vacations
all of that gets put on hold when you
have a kid in daycare according to the
u.s treasury department parents of
children under five years old pay on
average around 10 000 a year for child
care families currently need to devote
about 13 of their income to child care a
number the u.s treasury considers
unaffordable for most
smith is grateful for her job where her
salary is around double the average for
daycare workers in the state but she has
a master's degree and is a teacher by
trade a career she's put on hold to
afford child care what are you qualified
to make in bozeman between 65 and 70 a
year and right now you're bringing in 40
40. is that kind of a gut punch it it
it hurts a little bit jessica dane is
the owner of explore academy where smith
works she's committed to staying open
which means she's had to raise the price
she charges families to retain staff she
has to pay them competitively
what kind of competition are you facing
in terms of salaries out there right now
well it's very terrifying to have a
weekend because often my staff will go
to a social event and just get offered
five dollars more an hour what kind of
jobs are they leaving for honestly
a few have left to work in marijuana
grow
places
that kind of breaks my heart because i'm
like i could really use their skills and
their love and their passion with
children and the idea of that they're
picking buds is kind of
bums me out the child care system was
never working it was never working for
those that relied on it in order to put
food on the table it was never working
for those who used it as a career
chastity lord is the president and ceo
of jeremiah program which helps disrupt
poverty by supporting single moms and
their children she said child care is a
social justice economic and community
issue 90 percent of child care workers
are women 50 of those are women of color
their average pay is twelve dollars an
hour the average pay for someone
literally
serving coffee in our country is fifteen
dollars an hour
and so you are having people who sit at
the nexus of a child's development
who are literally working poor
back in billings montana moats is
closing discovery daycare and preschool
at the end of the month it's really hard
to look at a parent and know that
they don't have anywhere to take their
kids
and they still have to go to work
megan strickland is one of them she
attended the daycare as a child and now
her almost two-year-old daughter goes
here we don't have a plan yet i don't
know i don't know what we'll do
i have to stay working
that's not an option for our family
strickland is a nurse and pregnant with
her second child she's devastated by the
daycare closing i don't know what has to
change but something has to change
something's got to give at some point
for cbs morning's meg oliver bozeman
montana
got to change something's got to get you
just don't want it to be at the expense
of your children right
it's a broken system
yeah parents are paying too much and
then the child care workers are not
getting enough very bro question is
should government intervene
it's an ongoing conversation you're
right